all right good morning everybody welcome
to game engine API design ah
just for a quick feel of the room how
many of you are currently or have ever
worked in the games industry okay so
just a few of you cool so the way that
this talk ended up it's about game
engine API design but in order to
actually get into that API design you
have to sort of understand the
architecture behind the game engines
first in order for them to make sense
and so there's kind of two parts to this
talk the first part being an overview of
some of the common game engine
architectures that are popular in the
industry and then the second half will
be going more into the api's themselves
and what we can learn from them that
sort of stuff so I'm Alan Deutsch and
I'll be your presenter today before we
get started I just have a quick
disclaimer
so I'm employed by Microsoft and I work
under their gaming division and so in
that group I'm in the advanced
technology group and so we do a lot of
work with the major game developers and
other partners and create educational
content this is educational content
about games but it's completely separate
from work and so any of the views or
opinions or ideas expressed in this talk
are mine alone and don't represent
Microsoft or their gaming organization
or anything so if you're going to be mad
at someone be mad at me I like my job
please don't make me lose it all right
so my road to C++ now is sort of an
interesting story and I'm really honored
to be invited here as a speaker at such
a prestigious conference I'm sure
there's are an awful lot of conferences
here in Aspen and this is my favorite
one and hopefully it's some of your
favorites as well and by the end of this
talk that won't have changed so for me
it all started out on my first console
which was the gameboy color and so this
thing was pretty simple but back at the
day when I had it it was really exciting
to me it had this little gap in the back
that you could put cartridges in and
these little tiny plastic cartridges
contained hole where
that you could only really imagine
otherwise and that little scream there
was just a window into these other
worlds it wasn't all perfect though it
had this little indicator light here and
that thing it was red and as the battery
started to die it would dim along with
my hopes of you know getting to a save
point before the battery died so that
was by far my least favorite part of
this device but for me it all started in
this game pokemon red nose my first
video game and I really loved it because
it was this whole new world to explore
with all sorts of fantastic creatures
and you could train and grow as an
individual and everything and I became
fascinated with how you can go from you
know some concept in your imagination to
this real tangible world that people can
go live in and experience and so growing
up I always had in the back of my mind
how can something like that be done how
can it be made how can I create these
worlds and for me that grew beyond just
like how can I make it into how can I
learn about and create tools for other
people to be able to do it as well and
so my first experience with a game
engine was Unreal Engine and it was also
sort of my first real job because there
was this summer tech southerner tech
camp that I worked at it was called id
Tech I did that
right after I had finished high school
and one of the classes that I got to
teach there was an introduction to
Unreal Engine and so that was sort of my
first experience with helping other
people be able to take their ideas and
turn them into some tangible world and
that was really exciting for me so after
that I started my undergrad at DigiPen
Institute of Technology it's this small
little game development school in
Redmond focused on games and so I was in
the CS program and what's really
interesting about DigiPen especially for
me was that every year you form a team
with other students of various
disciplines so you'll have programmers
artists sound designers game designers
all these different fields and you all
work together to build a game and you
know that was this thing that I had been
so interested in growing up that it made
a lot of sense to me to have some
practical project wherever
I get to take all the things I'm
learning and put them together and make
something awesome with them so that was
great for me and I found myself in the
niche of game engines and so every year
on my teams I would build the sort of
core technologies that the rest of the
team would use to actually build
something and as an engine developer you
get to experience all sorts of
interesting programming problems because
you want to make it really easy for
everyone to use be they a developer or
some other non-technical sort of person
and so as a result of that I got pretty
deep into C++ and architecture as well
and I met some really great people here
there was this club called the game
engine architecture club and one of the
old leaders of it Sean Middleditch who
some of you may have know he's involved
with the standards committee a bit
co-chair of SG 14 so one year I was at
GDC with him and he invited me to come
to this SG 14 meeting so that was my
first experience with the committee
going from undergrad straight to like
the very best C++ programmers in the
world which was quite a jump for me and
by the end of it I had some idea of what
some of the people had said here and
there but most of it had gone over my
head at the time but he sort of jokingly
asked me what my proposal was and so we
talked about it for a bit and there's
this data structure called slot map
that's pretty popular in games and as it
turns out is pretty popular as a concept
in other industries as well and so I
ended up writing a proposal for that
which I've been working on and through
that proposal and sort of my other
involvement in C++ I ended up here at CP
CPP now last year and I presented a
lightning talk on the slot map data
structure so that was my sort of first
real public speaking engagement as it
were here at this conference and so
that's a big part of why C++ now has a
special place in my heart and so I've
I've sort of doped down that C++ rabbit
hole and gone pretty deep and learned a
few things and hopefully I can frame
them in the context of game engines and
architecture and API design and you'll
be able to get something
useful out of it so what exactly is a
game engine I'm sure you've probably
heard of them before but you may not
really know what they are it's a common
question I hear from people outside the
industry as well such as my parents and
friends who didn't go to DigiPen so if
you think of it as sort of like the
engine to a car that's actually not far
off because in a car the engine is
what's sort of powering it and helping
it move forward and in a game or a
simulation the engine is somewhat doing
the same thing it's the bits and pieces
inside that make everything work and
help it move forward and progress
through the different steps of a
simulation and in computing simulations
have discrete steps so you calculate say
a sixtieth of a second at a time in
fixed intervals or possibly dynamic
depending on the game but in more
practical terms a game engine is a
platform and so rather than targeting
Windows or Linux or Android or iOS
developer will target the game engine as
their platform and then the engine is
able to provide something like platform
abstractions so you build your game for
this game engine or using the game
engine and then it'll give you the
option to export to all of your
different target platforms that you're
interested in and so this makes it a lot
easier for you as a developer to focus
on just building your application and
then all of the platform dependent code
is abstracted away behind engine
interfaces and you don't have to know
about them they'll just work for you and
it's someone else's problem to solve
which is really convenient but a game
engine is about more than just platform
abstraction
it's also important for content creation
and collaboration so you have all these
different disciplines working on a game
the sound people artists programmers
designers and somehow they all have to
work together to create one cohesive
project so while all of your developers
are writing code for this engine artists
need to be able to import their assets
and so do sound designers and then some
game play developers and level designers
need to be able to place those things
and actually build the world and so a
game engine provides all of the tools
for that like resource loading and
processing and lots of optimizations so
that they can all work together and then
gives you a nice user interface that
someone who's not technical like a level
designer might be able to use to
actually put all of these different
separate pieces together and build
something cohesive so some of the common
technical functionalities inside of a
game engine are things like artificial
intelligence physics and graphics so
those are things that are generally
pretty common across all games and they
might provide them in different ways or
to different extents but in general
they're going to be offering some sort
of common functionality so that you
don't have to build everything yourself
so for AI for example it might have a
framework for implementing your own
behaviors whereas physics is relatively
the same across all different games with
some exceptions and so a physics engine
might be able to work the same for all
sorts of different titles without much
need for customization so the scope of
this talk needs to be narrowed down
because there's an awful lot that game
engines are able to do but there's one
core piece of functionality that's
really crucial for any of them to be
successful and what that is is the
ability for developers to implement new
behaviors so if you go to a game engine
and it doesn't have some feature that
you need out of the box you need a way
to create that yourself and so that's
the area of game engines that I really
want to focus on for this talk
so there's a lot of different
terminology throughout the games
industry and you know different engines
we use different terms to represent the
same thing so I want to go over sort of
the terminology that I'll be using so
that you understand conceptually what it
is in the context of games so the first
term is game logic that's basically just
the logic that powers your game so in
something like chess it would be the
rules for how a piece is able to move
the turns maybe a time limit for each
player and logic such as that when you
move a piece onto an opponent's piece
that piece has been captured so that's
sort of game logic if you're not from
the games background it's kind of like
business logic but in the games industry
we don't really think of what we do as
business so we call it game logic
instead of business logic the next one
is entity so the dictionary definition
of an entity is a thing with a distinct
and independent existence which is
pretty much spot-on for what we use it
for in the games industry if an entity
is any distinct thing so as long as you
have something in your game that can be
represented it's probably an entity so
that could be a tree an enemy the player
may be a rock somewhere and this
definition is pretty much spot-on with
what you'd expect on the independent
part is a little bit iffy in a game you
might have dependencies such as like a
parent-child relationship and so the
position in the world if something might
be dependent on where its parent is but
for the most part this would be what you
expect we also have components and so
components are the small little bits
that add functionality to an entity so
you might have say a component with the
transform data which would be its
position in the world its orientation
which is like where it's facing or how
its rotated and the scale of the object
so typically these components will be
attached to an entity to add either data
or behavior but depending on the
engine that can be used for other things
as well some use them as just like an
empty struct that's a tag specifying
some characteristic of the entity that
doesn't necessarily need any data or
logic associated with it some engines
use them just as data some have behavior
there as well so there's a lot of
variety across the industry for these
systems are another one so system is a
pretty broad term but in the context of
game engine architecture typically a
system would be something that performs
transformations on data so they're not
necessarily in all game engines and some
of them put game logic elsewhere but the
ones that do use systems tend to use
them for the game logic and so a system
will have some sort of dependencies for
what data it needs in order to operate
and then those dependencies will be
provided to it by the engine and it's
able to perform its data transformations
to help do its part in advancing the
simulation there's also a couple
different terms for types of games in
the industry so the sort of most
well-known games that you've probably
heard of things like Halo or overwatch
I called triple-a titles and so triple-a
basically just means it has a big budget
the cost of developing the game and the
cost of marketing the game are probably
in the same ballpark these titles are
generally backed by a major publisher
like EA or Ubisoft and so they have a
lot of resources available to them and
those publishers are able to do all
sorts of things for them like market
research that smaller studios might not
be able to do then on the complete
opposite end of the spectrum we have
indie games and so indie games or indie
in general is short for independent
developer and so in the purest sense
it's a game developed by the developers
with no publisher that has sort of their
own opinions being brought onto it
there's no you know open publicly traded
company that has shareholders to satisfy
and so there's a lot more freedom to
build what they want but they don't have
the same budget to make these grandiose
games with you know lots of different
functionality and
they tend to be smaller much smaller
development teams or even an individual
person and then rather than trying to
have like the greatest graphics and the
best physics and really pushing the
limits of the hardware these games are
generally a bit simpler and focus on
some unique or innovative mechanic that
the developer really wants to portray or
maybe a story that they want to tell so
those are the major differences between
the two types of games and there's a
whole spectrum between those two and
there are even other types of games such
as gambling or casino games which I
won't really be covering I'm not super
familiar with that part of the industry
but it is a major part of it they have
very different constraints than the rest
of us though in many ways so now that
we've got the terminology out of the way
let's talk about game engine
architecture so there's many different
ways to architect a game engine and now
that we know about all of these
different parts that go into them that
those game engines are composed of we
can take a bird's-eye view of some of
the common architectures that are more
well known and how they compose or how
they excuse me are composed of the
different basic parts so the first one
we're going to go over is the
inheritance hierarchy this is fairly
similar to in other domains you start
with some sort of base class in a game
it would be your entity and then as you
have you know different types of
entities you just inherit from that so
this base might have things like move
update animate render those sorts of
functionality and then those would be
virtual calls that the drive types can
implement based on the entity that it is
so if we have say a goblin and a wizard
maybe the Goblin moves by walking around
and it has different animations than a
wizard whose animations might involve
casting spells and it moves by
teleporting their logic could be
different as well with a boy a goblin
acting as perhaps part of a flock or
swarm and having some simple boid logic
whereas a wizard might have
bunch of spells that choose from and
casts so then if you have some more
derived type like an evil wizard you get
to reuse a lot of the functionality from
your wizard and just maybe change which
spells it has or how it makes its
decisions on what to cast so that's
fairly straightforward but sometimes it
doesn't work out so cleanly and we have
things like a goblin wizard and so if
you're familiar with inheritance you'll
know this is the dreaded diamond pattern
and so there are ways to work around
this in C++ with virtual inheritance but
it does leave other problems all those
base class functions are now ambiguous
so if you know explicitly on your goblin
wizard that you want to use the wizards
update and not the goblins then you can
do that explicitly but if that's not the
case and you need to modify it a bit
there's no real way to customize that
functionality you'll have to rewrite it
for your goblin wizard and so
reimplemented all this functionality
sort of does away with the advantages of
using inheritance and virtual calls for
code reuse
so maybe you do it a different way and
you have a goblin wizard that derives
from goblin and a human wizard that
derives from human and now you have
separate paths to it and you're able to
get by but now while this would work for
that situation
imagine later on you want to add some
other races like dwarves or elves and
now you have to go through and implement
wizard again in all of those different
classes and say you want to update the
behavior of a wizard or fix a bug now
instead of just having to do it in one
place you have to do it once for every
different type of character that could
be a wizard and then you know some of
those races maybe even have sub races
like a blood elf and a dark elf so
overall this solution isn't great and it
leaves a lot to be desired so in the
games industry we've looked at some
other options for how to fix this
one of those is with the entity
component architecture in this approach
you have your entity type and you have
component types and so the entity is
just some sort of connective tissue that
these different components can hook into
to work together so a component could
have a base functionality a store it
could not having a base does have some
advantages you can provide you know some
nice helper functionality to any of the
derived components for accessing each
other or working with the entity so some
examples of components you might have
are a model which tells you you know
what the physical characteristics of
your entity are how it looks and has the
information for how it can be rendered
you might also have a Collider so that's
the information needed for detecting
collisions in physics and so by doing
this you can implement that
functionality once and then you just
change which model it is depending on
the character and so then you implement
this logic once and you can attach it to
as many entities in whatever
combinations as you want so you get a
lot better code reuse here and then if
you want to change something you change
it in one place and it happens to
everything that needs that behavior so
this is pretty great there are some
issues though like there's dependencies
here in order to render a model you need
to know where it is so that you can
render it in the correct place and in
order to detect collisions you also need
to know where it is so that you can
detect those collisions in the correct
place it wouldn't be any fun if you have
some monster 20 feet in front of you
swinging his axe and it still registers
as a hit on you because even though
visually he's in one place the physical
location as far as your physics engine
is concerned is very different so that's
not a very good user experience so what
we'll actually do is pull out some of
that shared data into what's called a
transform component that I mentioned
earlier with the position and
orientation information and so those
components instead of holding their own
copy of the position in the model and in
the collider they'll get it from the
transform so this actually establishes a
sort of soft dependency because the
model and Collider don't necessarily
have to have the transform but they
don't really work correctly without it
so they need that data and they need a
way to access it
and then all of these different
components can be attached to your
entity so you can end up with something
like this where you have a model
Collider and a transform that are all
attached to your entity and then the
model and the collider can go through
your entity to get the data they need
from the transform so going back to our
example with the gameplay and you have
your humans and wizards and goblins and
all that this becomes a lot easier right
if you want to make something a human
you have a human component and you
attach it and you're done now it's a
human and that's pretty straightforward
now you can just make anything you want
a human and it may not have dependencies
on a specific model or other data so
it's fairly isolated and then you can do
the same thing with a wizard and so now
you have your human and your wizard
components and you can make all of your
changes to your wizard functionality in
one place and even if it's a human or
maybe you make it a goblin either way
they're using the same wizard
functionality and so as many races as
you add it scales linearly instead of
having to implement it multiple times
and make changes in a bunch of places so
you end up with a lot cleaner code this
way
so adding new races also become simpler
you just implement the component for
that particular race and then instead of
adding goblin or human you add that one
and any of these different classes that
you've made for your character like
wizard or you know Smith or whatever
they can all just be added to it one at
a time and there's no extra effort
needed if you want to add more so that's
pretty nice the complexity scaling in
this way goes from a sort of exponential
increase every time you want to add
functionality to much easier linear
increase adding one thing just makes it
one thing more complicated so this is
pretty great overall the complexity is
well managed logic is nicely contained
and the component can have data and
behavior together so that most of that
is self-contained and then some of that
shared data can be pulled out into
separate components like the transform
so that's pretty good but there are
still some tight couplings your logic is
tied to that data and there's not
necessarily a great way to express that
and so in practice in your code you
might have some component logic
somewhere that needs to go through the
entity to get another component and now
all of a sudden you've got a lot of
pointer chasing going on and games have
a lot going on in them there's a lot of
throughput that needs to happen and it
all has to happen very consistently in
time because you if you have 60 frames
rendered in your second that's great but
if 59 of them happen in the last 16
milliseconds and one of them takes the
entire rest of your second to render it
provides a really jarring user
experience and so we care not just about
throughput but also latency and having
those frames be consistently timed and
one of the issues with having all of
this pointer chasing is that it's
performance cost that's very low but it
happens everywhere in your codebase so
if you have your pointer chasing in all
of your code there's not some specific
place you can find with a profiler in
your hot path
that's really slow and needs to be
optimized and gives you a big win to
help you get your performance goals you
have to optimize basically the entire
way your engine and all of your gameplay
logic works and that's not very easy to
do so looking at our architecture
there's not really a good way to avoid
this so we might have to look at another
option if we need to optimize this and
that's more of a problem for the
triple-a industry than Indies typically
an indie studio isn't going to run into
the same level of performance issues
because their games are just smaller in
scope they're not going to have the same
hundreds of thousands of objects on
screen at a time or in a level there's a
lot less going on and so it's a bit
easier to manage
but in triple-a you need something else
and so there was a great keynote at CPE
Khan and I believe 2014 by Mike Acton
and so this talk was really
well-received it was called data
oriented design and C++ and this guy
came from a game studio that used C++
very much as though it were C with
classes and that's basically what he was
advocating for in this talk along with
basically organizing your logic so that
you just iterate over a raise of data
and perform transformations which has
great cache coherency and leads to a lot
less pointer chasing the CPU prefetcher
is able to do its job and everything
runs a lot faster and this talk was
really well-received not just by the
games industry but I think by the C++
audience in general if you go to the CPP
Khan YouTube channel and sort by views
it's actually number two and it's only
behind the next talk by about 1% so it's
one of the most popular C++ talks of all
time and it's very exciting and it's
surprising that someone was able to come
to a C++ conference and basically say
yeah we don't really use any of the
fiancie C++ functionality we just use C
with classes and that works for us and
it's fantastic and the talk was
well-received which is great
so there is a game engine architecture
that uses data oriented design so
looking at our sort of entity component
architecture we see a lot of issues with
this pointer chasing and we can mitigate
that a bit by putting these components
into arrays right so if we put all of
the components of a particular type and
an array together we're able to get a
lot better performance and we can update
these components wanted one type at a
time so you know update all of the
models update all the colliders probably
not in that order though because you'd
want to handle collisions before you
render things but it gives you a bit
better cache coherency and that's
something that can be done transparently
in that architecture without really
needing to change any of your user code
so that'll help a lot in removing some
of those cache misses that lead to round
trips out to memory but there are still
some issues we have all of those
dependencies between components so your
model and your collider need to access
the transform and for a particular
entity those may not be in the same
order so while trying to update your
model you could be jumping all over
memory going to your entity just to find
your transform data and if you have a
parent whose position changes where
yours is in the world then you have to
go to that parent as well and it becomes
a lot more complicated and so even
though we have some nice segmented data
that works together like the collider
and the transform and we're able to
iterate over them they might not both be
index aligned in memory so while one of
them would be cache coherent the other
would still be causing jumps in memory
so you get a good bit of performance
this way but you don't get everything
you need and so that works here with the
colliders it also works with the model
and transform but that has the downside
of still having all of those cache
misses so the next architecture is the
entity component system and what it does
is it sort of takes these structures and
it makes those dependencies more
explicit and it gives you the
opportunity to index align all of your
different types of components for a
particular object so that as you're
iterating over a set of them
you can see all right here's object one
here's object two here's object three
and instead of needing a specific entity
type you can just use an index into the
arrays and so the way an entity
component system works is rather than
having all of these different components
contain the logic that logic gets moved
out into systems and the components will
typically just contain data and so a
rendering system might need the
transform and model components while the
collision system needs transforming
Collider and then other systems can have
other dependencies and all of these
dependencies need to be more explicitly
laid out so you can sort of see at a
glance what logic needs what data and
that gives you a lot more opportunities
for optimizing as well as for managing
your complexity so that's sort of the
overview of our different architectures
for game engines that we're going to
look at so let's take a look at some
actual real world production game
engines that are actually used to ship
games today the first of which is unity
so unity is a really wildly popular game
engine and the previously mentioned Mike
Acton works there now and he's working
on some new stuff that isn't really
finalized yet so we're not going to go
into it in this talk but they're working
on building an entity component system
since that's not really done yet we're
not going to spend any time going into
the api's but it is something that will
be potentially a topic for future talks
but unity is quite possibly the most
popular game engine on the market today
it's incredibly popular especially for
things like mobile and VR and most indie
games today I would say are using unity
and I think the majority of you know
like the top 1,000 free mobile games are
built in unity as well and so unity
doesn't actually use C++ for the api's
they use a c-sharp scripting API but
behind the scenes the engine is actually
built in C++ and so they just exposed
the c-sharp API in order to gain some of
the functionality there and make it a
bit more approachable for
they're users and that something unity
has done really fantastically well it's
so easy to learn and pick up unity that
now a lot of online courses on
programming will start with game
development using unity and it's a
really great tool for learning
programming because unlike you know
making a little command-line a poor
hello world where you get some output
like hello world printed on your screen
which isn't very exciting when you're
learning game development in a game
engine your hello world is like a tree
or a character that you can press
buttons and it'll walk around and so
it's a lot more exciting and as someone
who's learning programming for the first
time you get a lot more interesting
feedback and positive feedback loops
that help you keep going and wanting to
continue learning so let's explore some
of their c-sharp api's and how they make
it easy for users to learn programming
and learn the engine and make games so
this first one here is a simple
component and so this has just sort of
the basic pieces that you need for a
component in unity so these are
functions that you can use like start
and update and putting them on your
class the engine will know what they are
and be able to call them automatically
so this is basically what you would get
something like this if you were to
create a new component through unities
editor which is there sort of GUI
front-end and so this snippet is
incredibly simple but there's some
interesting things we can observe here
the first is that unity components
inherit from a class called
monobehaviour and so that's the sort of
component base class that I mentioned
earlier it provides easy-to-use
functionality for things like accessing
the entity that it's attached to and
getting the data from the transform or
other components that you may need so
this works very similarly to how
inheritance works in C++ if you're not
familiar with c-sharp the main
difference is instead of specifying the
access here it's just whatever the base
class has or the mono behavior that's
the access that will be available to
your component
so it also has these methods start and
update and so you may note that they're
not virtual and there's no override
keyword there and in c-sharp in order to
override a virtual keyword or a virtual
method you need to use the override
keyword which isn't present here so
they've actually got what we could call
magic methods and these methods are ones
that are specifically known by the
engine and they're documented as
functions you can add to your component
and if they're present the engine will
automatically call them for you at the
appropriate time so that's very similar
to how virtual method works but as C++
programmers I'm sure you all know that
there's some overhead associated with a
virtual function call and so by using
these magic methods and having a way of
detecting that they're there it's
possible to get better performance
because you don't have those same
virtual dispatchers happening so in
unity this functionality is implemented
using reflection so c-sharp has
reflection as a language level feature
and we don't have that yet in C++ but
hopefully in the future we will but
these are specifically named functions
so there are ways to find them so first
there they have a fixed signature so we
know that anytime there's like a start
function or an update function it'll be
of the form void with a specific name
and then no arguments and so instead of
needing to search for any function on a
class we actually just have to be able
to find these specific ones and so that
is a problem but it's something that we
can solve in reflection with tools like
sven a and if you were here at c++ now
last year the odds are good you might
actually know an even better solution
there was a talk presented by marshal
Clow that has an even better way of
doing this and so that talk was on the
detection idiom or as he calls it a
better way to see nay so this is really
great because it basically gives you a
way of saying hey I want to know if this
code would compile for a given type T
and so you can basically say you know
for this T which would be whatever the
users component is if I were to call
update on it would that
code compiled and so the detection idiom
seeks to answer that question for you
in a way that will compile and give you
a true or false answer regardless of
whether the code you're asking about
would actually compile itself so let's
take a look at what code for that might
look like so there's basically three
parts that we have for detecting an
update function so let's take a look at
each of them one at a time
the first one is the detection meta
function so this is where the code that
you want to test out and see if it would
compile will live so there's a few parts
to it the first is sort of this
boilerplate where we declare our alias
template and so that should be fairly
straightforward to the audience here so
I won't go into that too much the next
part is our meta function itself and so
we use deckle type because that gives us
an unavailable to exist here even though
it wouldn't compile in an evaluated
context and we're still able to test
against it so within this deckle type on
evaluated context there are also a
couple parts to pay attention to the
first is stood deckle Val and so what's
the deckle val does is whatever type you
give it
it'll add in our value reference and
then return or at least its signature
we'll say that it's going to return that
our value qualified type so for us
passing in our T reference on the
collapsing semantics for references will
give us the T reference that we put in
and so this function isn't actually
defined anywhere there's no body to it
that actually exists so if you were to
put this in an actual evaluated context
it would fail to compile but since we
have it living inside of a none
evaluated context we're able to do this
and get something that resolves as a
reference to a T that we can then try to
call methods on to detect if they're
available so the next part is the
function that we want to detect so
that's our update function and since we
have something that resolves as a T
reference we can try to call update on
it in this unev al u ated context
and that's basically the the gist of
what we're trying to figure out here is
if this particular code would compile
for a given T so with that we have all
we need for our meta function and we can
dive into actually using the detection
idiom so it's pretty straightforward
here you basically define a type trait
with it
so ours is called has update again we
have our boilerplate template alias and
that's not too interesting then here we
have our call to is detected and so this
functionality is actually currently
proposed in the library fundamentals to
us so there's a good chance that in the
next you know two to five years we'll
actually have this in the standard
library and be able to use it but the
code is freely available online you can
search Google for the detection idiom
and I'm sure you'll be able to find a
working implementation somewhere but the
way it works is really straightforward
you basically just say is detected and
then you pass in your meta function as
the first argument and T is the second
argument for the type you want to test
against that meta function and so the
type that's returned to you will have
some static public member named value
that either resolves as true or false
depending on whether your code would
compile in that meta function for the
provided T and there's even fancier
stuff you can do with this we don't
really need it for this talk so I won't
get into it but if you're interested I
definitely recommend checking out
Marshalls talk which gives you the whole
hour of depth on this particular
approach so then finally we're
programmers and we're really lazy so we
want to get a variable template for this
so that we can just use has update v4 RT
and our autocomplete will give us a bit
more mileage and it's easier to use so
that's just sort of nice to have feature
another thing of note here though is
that this is actually contacts per so
we're able to detect this information at
compile time and then we can use compile
time branching for things like if Const
x fur or selecting overloads using speen
a2 branch what happens in our logic and
so all of that overhead gets moved to
compile time and then at runtime we have
no extra overhead so just like unities
c-sharp approach we're able to provide
these magic methods
have no runtime overhead associated with
them so there's a few of these that we
want and in unity there's nearly 70 of
these special named functions that you
can use and that's a lot to implement so
we can use a little macro that generates
all of our boilerplate for us and then
you just pass in the name of the
function you want to detect and it'll
find it for you and if you want to get
really fancy you could build one of
these that takes different numbers of
arguments as well with particular types
as the parameters but we don't really
need that for this example so I'll leave
that as an exercise to you the viewer so
what we can't do yet there are some
things that c-sharp gives unity in
reflection that allow C sharp and unity
to implement much nicer features than
some of the things we can do in C++ one
of the biggest influence of this is
messaging so here we have an example of
a component that broadcasts a message
and so you can see that logic happening
here and where you see game object just
think entity a game object is unities
name for an entity but they're
effectively the exact same thing and so
here you can broadcast a message on a
game object so the way that this works
is they pass in a string name for the
function that they want so you can see
here we have apply damage and then apply
damage is also a function and so we
don't have a way to go from a string
name in C++ to a function and
additionally this doesn't just work on
your class it'll actually go to your
entity that the component is attached to
and it'll call that function on any
other components that have it on the
entity as well and it doesn't stop there
it'll also do it for any children that
are parented to your entity so that
gives them a lot of flexibility and they
have this really nice event system that
doesn't really require any advanced
understanding of how events work and you
can pass parameters to it which will go
to any of those functions and if the
function doesn't happen to take that
parameter it just gets ignored and they
have additional traits you can use as
well
and so this is really neat because it
lets you basically implement your events
whatever way you want and so while we
can detect a specific function if we
know it at compile time they use strings
as a runtime value which means they
could actually wire up events at runtime
in like some other scripting language or
through a GUI editor and they don't need
to know that information at compile time
and since those functions could have any
name we can't really use the detection
idiom to detect them because we don't
know their name at compile time so this
is something that might be available to
us in the future in C++ once reflection
is standardized or if reflection is
standardized but today we don't have a
way of implementing this very cleanly so
another thing that they are able to get
out of reflection is a sort of GUI
front-end that's generated automatically
so you as a user can implement some sort
of component in this one we have it
called level script and you can put
whatever public members you want and
since unity has reflection it can just
go over your class and detect what all
of those public members are and what
their types are and just expose them in
a GUI automatically and the user doesn't
have to write any additional code to
make this happen so this is really
helpful because if you have some
non-technical person like a designer
they can just go in and click on an
entity and modify values on its
components and you never had to write
any reflection code you had never had to
write on a GUI code it's all
automatically generated and so this
makes it a lot easier to collaborate
with people and there's a lot less
overhead for the programmer in order to
support that
so the same is true of other features as
well for example in a game it's really
common to want to serialize data so
that's taking your you know programming
language representation of it and
converting it into some other format
like JSON or a binary representation and
that's useful because games often need
to save their state or load levels or
send information over a network
and so having reflection makes it
possible to generate all of that
automatically instead of having to do it
for all of your types by hand so that's
quite useful and then it also makes it
easier to deserialize which is taking
that separate representation of your
types and then converting them back into
the representation in your programming
language so this is functionality that's
really important in games and the
engines that are built in C++ have
really horrible workarounds for it so
one approach is building your own custom
C++ parsing tool nowadays that might be
done using clang but one of the other
popular game engines called Unreal
Engine that I mentioned earlier they've
actually been doing this for a lot
longer than clang has been around and so
they have their own custom header tool
and the way that people are able to use
it is above a member they're able to say
you know you property for unreal
property and then they have things like
network synced so it'll automatically be
synchronized over network and
serializable and specifying the name of
it in the editor there's other ways of
doing it as well there's this game
engine called lumberyard made by Amazon
and the approach that they take is
building out a really nice reflection
library so you don't have to write all
of these sorts of code by hand but what
you have to do is manually register all
of your types in their reflection engine
one member at a time which is horrible
if you could just write your code and
all of that reflection is generated for
you it's a much better experience for
developers than having to explicitly
implement your reflection for all your
types by hand and it gets even worse
because there's a lot of different
contexts in which your data might be
reflected and so you may end up having
to implement that reflection code
multiple times for the same type because
you want one context for the editor and
a different context for serializing um
so overall it provides a pretty terrible
experience and so reflection is one of
those features that game developers are
really looking forward to in C++ because
our other solutions are not nearly as
good today but it's possible to build
tools that'll generate it all for you
and clang but that's still a lot of work
and having it as a language feature
would be really nice so let's take a
look at some of the other api's that
unity has for interacting with
components and entities so one of them
is getcomponent and so here's an example
that demonstrates that so you have one
component and it needs to get another
component so ours is get component
generic example here this is from the
Unity documentation somewhere and so
just like before we have to inherit from
monobehaviour because we're implementing
a component so that's fairly
straightforward still and then here we
have this hinge joint type which is some
other kind of component and so we
specify it and then we can get our
component using a sort of generic
interface kind of like templates in C++
so since we're accessing a component of
one type from a component of another
type
we're actually establishing a dependency
here and so unity has a way of making it
a soft dependency so all of these types
in unity and c-sharp are reference types
and so we can check if it's null and in
this way we're able to make it a soft
dependency instead of a hard dependency
our function will still work if it's not
there and we just have some additional
logic for if it is so this is a pretty
nice way of handling the dependencies
and there are some issues that arise if
you don't have this sort of soft
dependency thing on for example if you
have a hard dependency you could check
that it's there before allowing the user
to attach a component but then you could
run into issues with deserializing where
if you're loading something from memory
or another representation and a
component with a dependency
is loaded before the dependency itself
you run into issues or if you have two
components that both depend on each
other then neither of them can be added
until the other is there and you run
into issues and so having this sort of
soft dependency as an option is great
but there are issues with it for example
these dependencies are sort of declared
wherever in the code it could be in any
of those nearly seventy different magic
functions or even some other method on
the class that is called by one of them
so it's not easy to figure out what your
dependencies actually are so then here
again we have our game object and this
game object is again our entity type in
unity and so one of the things here is
that in order to get another component
you have to go through the game object
and so now we have a dependency not only
on the component itself but also the
game engine and in order to get to the
component we have to jump through memory
from our component to the game object
and then from the game object to that
other component so we're running into
those same issues with cache misses so
there are some other things that might
be familiar to us this snippet is taken
from the documentation on transform
parenting and unity which is basically
how you establish a parent-child
relationship between entities so here is
where we set the parent right we have a
player dot transform parent and player
is an entity instance and then we're
able to set the parent there and so the
way that parenting works it's actually
on the transform in unity not the entity
itself on which sort of makes sense
because the the main reason for
parenting is so that you have relative
positions so in unity the transform is
actually built into the entity type so
instead of having to jump through memory
to go from your entity to your transform
they're together in memory so you at
least save one cache miss there because
nearly every entity in a game engine
will have a transform on anything in a
game probably is somewhere so there are
not a lot of cases where you would need
an entity and not a transform so this
design sort of makes sense it is
able to buy them a little bit more
performance and then this parent member
is a reference to another entity
somewhere in this case the new parent
that was passed into this function so
here we have some code that uses that
parent information so we have the
players transform parent and then we
want to print the name of it and so this
code is really easy to write just like
as a developer or someone who's new to
programming this logic isn't complicated
it's very simple there's not a lot of
syntactic overhead and so this code is
really easy to write and as a result it
tends to exist all over in the code
bases of games made in unity and there
is a downside to this because while it's
really easy there's a lot of pointer
chasing going on and if you're not
someone who knows a lot about low-level
programming and hardware on this isn't
gonna look like code that's slow there's
nothing exciting going on here it's just
like you're getting the name of your
parent which is really straightforward
but there's actually a few things
happening here first we have to jump
from this component to the player so
that's our first potential cache miss
and there's some performance overhead
there and then that may not be stored
contiguously so not ideal then the next
part is that we have to go from that
player and it's transform which are
again together in memory so that's
probably an l1 cache hit the performance
overhead isn't bad but we have to go
from there to the parent and we don't
really know where the parent could be so
in our worst case scenario that's
another cache miss and then finally we
want to get our parents name and so that
name would be most likely a string and
I'm not sure the specific working
implementation details of strings in
unity and c-sharp but if we assume that
it has a sort of small buffer
optimization like we haven't C++ that
would make sense but in our worst case
scenario that name is longer than the
small buffer optimization allows and so
it's another cache miss because it has
to jump out to heap memory somewhere in
order to get that string so just for
this simple code here we've had
potentially three cache misses and so if
you have this code once it's not a big
deal but if you have it in tight loops
all over your game and all of your
different components the cost starts to
add up really quickly and a game could
have a hundred thousand different
entities in it and each
those entities could have a dozen or
more components and if all of those
components are being updated 60 times a
second you end up with a lot of cache
misses going on every second and all of
a sudden your performance starts to
degrade and there's no one place you can
optimize to fix it because it's just
everywhere you know death by a thousand
paper cuts so from here we can see that
unity has components and entities so
it's pretty clearly the component entity
architecture and in a real production
system of course you're probably not
going to stick
completely strictly to an architecture
and they have other things like their
event system that don't necessarily fit
perfectly in that model but overall
unity has done a really fantastic job at
its goal on the company mission is to
democratize game development and by
making it so approachable and easy
they've done a really excellent job at
that and now there are millions of game
developers that probably never would
have been able to explore that as a
potential career path or a hobby if it
weren't for tools like unity that make
it a lot more accessible to them
building a game engine yourself is a ton
of work and it requires a ton of domain
knowledge and so having something like
unity that provides a simple easy to use
tool for doing that has done a lot of
great things for the game industry so
that's fantastic but when it comes to
the triple-a industry which is those
games that are really trying to push the
boundaries on graphics and performance
and really get the maximum amount of
performance they can out of their
hardware
all of these cache misses and unity add
up a bit too much and they're really not
able to use it because that's something
that can't easily be optimized in that
architecture and since that code is
hidden away as something that you as a
developer don't have access to you can't
even do anything about it so in the
triple-a industry maybe surprising but
off-the-shelf solutions are not very
commonly used unreal is used a bit but
not super extensively and in the past
four years of the laketop 30 by revenue
or gross income Triple A titles
only like three or four of them used an
off-the-shelf game engine all the rest
of them used their own custom in-house
engine be it developed by that studio or
possibly by the same publisher or some
other studio within the publisher so one
of the really successful triple-a titles
in recent memory is a game called
overwatch and so before its release in
May of 2016 the overwatch open beta had
nearly 10 million players that's just
the beta not even the final release so
the the difference in scale for
something like this versus a game made
in unity is huge
a typical Unity game might have as few
as tens of downloads where it's just the
person who made it and some friends or
it could go into millions or even tens
of millions but they wouldn't typically
operate at the same scale a year and a
half after this game came out it had 35
million players and that's still been
climbing and so in addition to being a
wildly successful triple-a title they
also pushed the boundaries on engine
design a bit and they've been using some
of the more recent architecture
developments in the industry and so if
you're interested in that sort of thing
there's a talk from the Game Developers
Conference or GDC and they have an
online vault of their talks you have to
pay for access so if you're not in the
games industry it's probably not
worthwhile for you but if you are I
definitely recommend the talk it's
called game play architecture and net
code and it's presented by a guy named
Timothy Ford who was on the overwatch
team and so it has a lot of information
about how the game engine was structured
and some of the lessons they learned and
a lot of the tricks they use to have
seamless networking code for the
perspective of the user so we can't
really go into all of that but I'd like
to explore some of the design decisions
they've made with their API and so this
slide right here which is taken from
that talk actually includes I think just
about all of the C++ code that was in
that presentation and I know it's small
and you probably can't read it I have
slides where it's blown up a bit bigger
so don't worry about reading it here
but the engine is written in C++ and so
this is all of what was shown in the
talk so it's a lot to take in at once so
we'll break it down a bit so the first
is that they use component tuples so
this one here is a physics tuple and it
has three different kinds of components
on it so one of the advantages of this
is that now these dependencies have been
declared in advance and it's known by
the type system so you can see anything
that uses a physics tuple has
dependencies on those three types of
components another thing to note is that
it has pointers directly to them so
there's no sort of middleman entity
class that you have to go through in
order to get them which takes one
potential cache miss out of the equation
another advantage of this approach is
that by using pointers they can change
how their components are stored behind
the scenes and that's invisible to the
user you don't have to know what
container they're in you don't have to
know where they are in memory you don't
know have to have to know how they're
laid out and as long as these three
components are all pointed at components
that are associated with the same entity
conceptually it still does what you need
it to and through this sort of interface
you don't have a way of accessing other
components so you can't just take on
extra dependencies somewhere else in
code where it's not easy to find all
these are laid out ahead of time so
that's one of the big advantages of this
approach so they also use data oriented
design so here's an example of some game
logic that uses those tuples they have a
range based for a loop that loops over
the result of some get physics tuples
function and they're able to get the
components they need from that tuple and
so they have some container that gets
returned by that function we don't
necessarily know what it is and it
doesn't actually matter but given that
they want performance it's pretty safe
to assume that this is probably an array
or some other array like container so
they're able to get good cash
performance out of it and behind the
scenes whatever optimizations they're
doing for the memory layout of the
components is invisible to the user but
is still optimizable if it becomes an
issue they can still go in and change it
and it doesn't break all of their
gameplay code
everywhere so that's a pretty great
design as far as adding surface area for
optimization options so while there's
shockingly little code in this sample
there's actually a lot of information
that we can use to figure out more about
the architecture of the overwatch engine
so clearly it has components and those
components e's are explicitly specified
but you can't really tell what the
architecture is from what's on screen
currently if you were able to read that
whole slide you might know but the
answer is actually that it has a physics
system so that's where this code snippet
lives it's in there physics system so
now we know that this game engine has
some concept of components and it has
some concept of systems and a systems
dependencies are expressed through those
component tuples but curiously there's
nothing that really appears to be an
entity type it's actually been hiding in
plain sight and those component tuples
are the entity type and so there's not a
single entity type that everything goes
through they have specialized ones for
each system depending on what its
dependencies are and so in this way the
entity type doesn't actually need to
exist um so we have it here the physics
tuple but there's different
representations of it for different
systems and instead of giving you a
generic interface that lets you do
whatever you want
it has some constraints on it which
gives them more opportunities for
optimization and it gives the user less
opportunities to do things that are
expensive and will add up to high
performance cost and you know a death by
thousand paper cuts sort of approach so
with the sort of triple play of these
entities components and systems we can
determine that this is almost certainly
an entity component system architecture
and in this particular case you don't
have to take my word for it because in
the talk they've actually called it in
ECS and so we know for sure that that's
what it is
but I still think it's an interesting
exercise to look at the interfaces for a
system and use that to determine how
it's our
detected behind-the-scenes and it's in
fascinating for me observing how the
architecture of a system and the
interface for it have influence on each
other and designing your system with a
particular architecture sort of informs
the interface and building your
interface in a certain way sort of
informs how it gets architected behind
the scenes so it does get better though
in addition to telling us that it's an
EC s they also shared some insights
about how it's used and some of the
patterns for usage that emerged so one
of the things that's not really shown
here but a lesson that's a takeaway is
they have components that are only data
and then their systems are only logic so
there's no mixing of those two and then
any shared functionality goes off in
utilities somewhere as like C style
functions but some systems do need State
in some way right if you have a system
that manages your window where the game
is actually rendered - it needs at the
very least a native handle to that
window and if it has no state at all
there's no way to operate with that so
what they've done is they've used within
the model of an entity component system
something that they call singleton
components and so that's a component
that there's only one of at a time and
what they'll do is they'll put the
system state and those sort of singleton
components and so then there's some
other advantages of this as well because
if there are other systems that need the
same data they know how of a way of
accessing that data without taking on a
dependency to the other system and so on
this way they're able to architect it in
such a way that there are no
dependencies between systems and there's
no systems that call functions on each
other so that's great
another thing that's interesting is that
declaring these dependencies ahead of
time has some advantages so on this
slide from them you can see a column of
systems and a couple columns of
components don't worry about reading
them it's not important the only thing
that matters here really for us is the
stuff that's highlighted in blue in
those columns
so there are six systems highlighted and
something like 13 or so components and
the reason that they're highlighted is
because those dependencies being
declared ahead of time they also have a
way of expressing if a dependency is
read-only and so if you know whether
something is going to be read access
only or read and write you can actually
make decisions about multi-threading
based on that right if you have two
systems that only write two different
data and any shared data is read only
you can actually safely execute those in
parallel and so those six systems on the
left and the thirteen components on the
right represent systems that can run in
parallel and their dependencies and so
they have a bunch of slides on this
showing all of the different ones that
they have and the takeaway is that
through this approach not only do you
add the ability to optimize things based
on memory layout but you can also
improve performance by doing
multi-threading and because you have
contracts sort of at your API level with
the user you can do this multi-threading
behind the scenes and do it in such a
way that it's safe and it's invisible to
the person implementing logic and so all
of a sudden you can have like game
designers with a little bit of technical
experience but certainly no deep
knowledge of multi-threading write code
that's safely multi-threaded and so that
gives you this whole additional vector
for improving performance so another
thing is that the way they access
components is through this sort of
function so there's a downside to this
right whenever you want to implement a
new function or a new system you have to
write one of these and you probably have
to define your tuple type as well for
the component tuples that you need so
that's not ideal it means you have to
write a lot of extra code that's
boilerplate that really is the same
everywhere with only slight differences
being the different types of components
you want and so in the world of C++ we
have very attic templates which are
really great at expressing this sort of
concept right you have something and a
variable number and types of types so we
can actually
express this sort of request as you know
the way you can interpret this is the
system wants all of the entities with a
particular set of components so if we
were to implement that we could do it
something like this right you have a
class called entities with and then you
have some template arguments and then
when the users writing their code they
would say something like entities with
and then lists out the types of
components they want which is both
incredibly expressive because anyone
reading the code can see it and
immediately know what those dependencies
are and it also provides a generic
interface so you can implement this code
one time and use it everywhere and it'll
work the same for everyone and then if
you need to optimize it you do it in one
place instead of everywhere so how this
works behind the scenes can vary on all
it really needs in order to fit that
model that the overwatch engine was
using is a begin begin and end iterator
and then those iterators have to have
some sort of type that gives them access
to the components that they listed so
what this might be storing is
potentially a stood tuple right that's
the sort of obvious equivalent to what
they're doing in a generic context you
can put whatever template arguments are
on this entities with type into the
tuples have like a vector of them that's
easy and if you want to change the
container behind the scenes you can do
that and it doesn't really affect the
user code anywhere but tuples have a
kind of terrible interface and so if you
have people who aren't necessarily
advanced C++ users and they're more used
to like just really basic code I'm
having to do like get zero and know that
that's a particular component isn't
really ideal and reading the code it's
not very clearly expressed either so we
could have some sort of intermediate
representation or our own type on like
an entity that's been constrained based
on which components you've specified
here so we could do that with something
like a constrained entity type that's
also a very attic template and so it
would store those in the
and then through this constraint entity
type we could provide a much prettier
interface for the user to use in order
to access their components so another
advantage here is that all of these
component types we can constant at their
read-only and so now that read-only
versus read and write access is
specified explicitly through the type
system and there's no sort of extra
functionality we need so if we have that
we can also provide an interface
depending on whether something is
constant or not so if we were to give
some sort of get function for components
we can choose which overload is
available based on the contract miss and
then since those are different functions
on in our implementation somewhere we
can check if the constant is matched
with the way that they specified it in
the entities with container and so by
doing so we can give them some nice
clean easy to read error because we have
all of the context available to us using
like a static assert and say hey this is
wrong here's why it's wrong you need to
change your constant Nisour request this
in your entities width so that gives us
a way of really explicitly declaring our
dependencies and then enforcing them at
compile time as part of the type system
and providing clear error messaging to
the user so now if a user wants to
implement a system say like some really
simple physics stuff it could look like
this right they have a velocity system
it has an update function that takes the
Delta time for the frame and then they
again have a range based for with some
sort of function called get entities
with and they list out there correctly
Const qualified components and then they
get some sort of entity representation
which we're calling a here and they can
get their components off that using the
same familiar interface from unity and
so here we have really simple game logic
right we have a position and we're just
adding the velocity scaled by the time
Delta for this frame so that's pretty
straightforward and then we have all the
dependencies expressed explicitly with
our get entities with function so that's
pretty straightforward and then getting
the components we have to have the
correct constants here
the constant has to match in order for
that to work so there's where we sort of
get all of our components and accessing
them uses a really similar interface to
what they might be used to from working
in unity this code overall is fairly
concise there's not a lot of extra stuff
going on here beyond what the programmer
wants but there is a decent amount of
boilerplate we have our magic method as
well the update and so adding a
parameter to it such as the delta time
is really easy we just in our meta
function we would put in a float inside
the call to update and then it would
still work for this case so this is a
pretty good approach but can we make it
better if we take a look at sort of
what's here we have all of this logic
which isn't necessarily the logic for
our game right we have to declare this
class we have to make things public we
have to loop over all of these entities
with things and then from that we have
to get our components off of that entity
type and then we have to have our
closing braces and everything so overall
only about half of this code is what
actually does our game logic on so
there's a lot of extra boilerplate there
that has to be implemented every time
and we may not actually need it so what
if we could write code without all of
that right what are the things that we
actually need we have a function and if
we want our logic to have any sort of
organization to it we're gonna need
functions to make that a bit cleaner and
so it takes in the Delta time for the
frame which is something we need in
order to perform our game logic so that
still makes sense we also need our
components and we need to know their
types and the correct constants of them
so that's something we can't avoid
either but this is something that could
be potentially taken in as a parameter
to the function and then finally we have
the game logic itself so this is what
actually does the work and obviously we
can't get rid of that either so if we
were to make some system code that has
our absolute minimum amount of code
necessary so that the developer writes
just
what they need and nothing else maybe it
could look like this right you have your
update function you take in the delta
time and then references to the
components you want and much like in the
overwatch engine on this makes it
transparent to the user how that data
gets there they just get a reference to
it and behind the scenes that could just
be stuff that's stored linearly in
memory so all of the calls to this
function would be very cache friendly
and it's a surprisingly small amount of
code compared to what we had before I
mean if we compare it we have all of
this versus just basically two lines of
code and then a closing bracket so this
is great and it gives us a lot of
opportunity to optimize as well if we do
it in this approach where the the for
loop over all of the entities happens
within the type there's nothing we can
do to optimize that but if we have it
here where it's just a function does one
step of it we could actually put calls
to this function in something like a
parallel for loop and then execute
individual systems in parallel as well
so it gives us a lot of opportunity to
optimize our code even further if we
need to which is an advantage here we
get a lot more possibility for
multi-threading and so these functions
could have any sort of signature right
we don't know what the components are
ahead of time a user could specify their
own new types of components and all
sorts of different functions that take
them as parameters so our approach to
detecting from before probably wouldn't
work as well because we're not really
detecting a specific signature anymore
in practice we might want some extra
data as well in this case the float DT
or possibly other state and that could
be moved out into components as like a
singleton approach like overwatch but
maybe not so we have you know maybe our
example is something like a class where
we have a function that does all of the
data processing and some state and we
want to make sure that the user doesn't
modify any of that state while their
call is being executed in some sort of
parallel context um so we have a way of
making that contract to the type system
as well using const so we just make this
a constant member function and so now
our detection needs to be basically a
function with a particular name
any class and there's one of them but it
could have any signature so that's a bit
of a different problem and it's pretty
difficult and I had some trouble with it
but I went on the CP Lang slack and
Nicole mizuka sorry if I pronounced that
wrong sent me this code which is
basically a way of detecting if
something is a member function
regardless of what the signature is and
since we only care about a constant
version of it since we want to execute
it in a parallel context we don't need
the additional overloads but they're
easy to make if you need them and then
we have our you know bull shorthand
version of it so this lets us detect if
something is a member function then if
we want to detect specifically our
process member function we get code like
this and so we use that as member
function with the name of our function
that we want on T and if it exists we
get a true value back and if it doesn't
exist then we get a false value back so
now we're able to detect any signature
with a particular name as long as
there's no overloads this doesn't handle
that but again that's something that we
could do potentially in the future with
reflection where we're able to iterate
over the members but today we can only
support one at a time and then if you
wanted to take this and sort of slim it
back down into the C style version where
there's no state it's even easier to do
so with this we can detect if there's
that process method there and use it so
we're able to write code that looks like
this and we have tons of opportunities
to optimize it and we can make our
contracts with the user of our code
through the type system so there's a lot
less overhead and boilerplate and we
still have all of the same
expressiveness and performance that we
would want so the big takeaway here is I
think just think about how your systems
are architected and how your API is for
them architected and what your potential
performance issues could be and how you
can change your interface to give you
more opportunities to solve those
problems so thank you for coming to my
talk if you have any questions or
comments I'm happy to take them and if
you're watching the recording feel free
to email them to me so any questions
Thanks yeah using concepts instead of
inherent so the question is has anyone
looked at using concepts and type
erasure instead of inheritance I don't
know there's a lot of people out there
and most of the game code bases live in
sort of isolated environments where we
don't have a lot of insight into them
even the stuff for like overwatch we're
only able to know because they presented
it in a talk there's no like
documentation or download available
where you can get that code so I don't
know of anyone that's done it but if
it's something you're interested in you
could always do it give a talk on it
next year
alright no other questions okay so the
question is if you have the perspective
of structure of arrays versus arrays of
structures if there's any sort of
tooling that can automatically convert
from one to the other
I don't recall the name of it but I know
someone was working on a sort of helper
type that would provide a sort of class
like interface to structure to an
structure of arrays back-end so there's
stuff out there but it's not well-known
yet and I'm not sure how polished or
tested it is yet but I believe it is
possible to do so and depending on what
you want your interface to look like
that could change how easy or difficult
it is to make
go onto the committee with the
interesting things I mean you've
obviously got a couple of things here
where it's like well I can already do it
detecting information I would say the
absolute minimum would be given a
particular type knowing what its data
members are so that we can take those
and build a GUI front-end for them or
serialize the type load it back from
memory that sort of work and do so in a
sort of generic context in the games
industry most of the reflection is
runtime not compile time reflection
because a lot of game engines will allow
users to extend things in a scripting
language such as Lua or c-sharp and that
information isn't known at compile time
so they need to be able to extend their
reflection data at runtime in order to
be able to work with those types
additionally the games industry has had
these sort of urgent problems for quite
a while and so we already have our own
solutions to them that are built like I
said lumberyard has their own reflection
engine unreal has their header tool and
then the approach I'm trying to use is
building all of the reflection we need
using clang as sort of a build step
right
yeah so typically the scripting
languages that are used have some sort
of metadata available Lua has table
information c-sharp has reflection
built-in and so if you have oh sorry the
question was about reflection relating
to the standard proposal and what the
needs of the game industry are so we're
able to sort of take that information
and implement the code to map that into
our own reflection infrastructure so
whatever we have behind the scenes we're
able to add on at runtime which is
something that might not be possible
with static or compile time reflection
approach as I've seen with the proposals
yep other questions
no I think that is a factor for some of
them but if you look at like the
overwatch code there's nothing there
that couldn't have been implemented in
C++ 98 besides like the range based for
loop and there's an approach that solves
that it's just not as pretty that's the
difference right so I don't think
necessarily that's what it is but I
think having the modern features
definitely makes a lot of these things
nicer it makes them a lot easier to work
with and to implement and so the lack of
compiler support for some of the
platforms like especially the consoles
and handheld platforms does hold it back
somewhat but I think more so it's that a
studio might have a 20 year history and
if they built an engine they're not
going to completely rebuild it as these
new patterns come out because they
already have it they've already spent
the time optimizing it and so the value
to go back and completely rewrite it
isn't as high and so as long as they're
still hitting the performance targets
they have there's less of a need to
rewrite it in a new way oh and the
question was if there are if I think
that lack of compiler support for modern
standards in the C++ language are
holding back the architecture of game
engines
all right thanks everyone
[Applause]